just a simple meal but we can imagine
what it meant to these people after
spending almost two months at sea in
inhumane conditions Indonesian fishermen
brought them ashore in lanza in arch a
region on Friday after coming across
their sinking boat nearly 800 people
were crammed aboard the passengers
described a harrowing journey as food
supplies began to run short fighting
broke out some people were thrown
overboard the migrants are Bangladesh's
and Rohingya my aunt must Muslim ethnic
minority the Rohingya our frequently
subject to persecution in mainly
Buddhist Myanmar my President does not
like Muslims he said he would put us in
prison for 20 30 or 40 years the UN's
refugee agency estimates that 25,000
Rohingya and Bangladesh is bordered
traffickers boats in the first quarter
of this year alone but neighboring
countries Malaysia Thailand and
Indonesia don't want to accept more
refugees I do not tear
I want to do too much here after they
are floating in and she
you shall men help us the United Nations
has appealed to the regional governments
to take in the boat people and urge them
not to push the migrant vessels back out
to sea what will ultimately happen to
these people remains unclear